[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the development of gmp
manufactured cas9 protein for
therapeutic applications
i am robert horton of thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational webinar seminar
is presented by lab roots brought to you
by thermal fissure scientific to learn
more about cts cas9 or related crispr
products please visit
www.thermalfisher.comcast9
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentations to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
with that out of the way i'd like to
welcome our speaker pandita potionard
pandita is a product manager for the
genome modulation and editing group at
thermal fish scientific where she is
responsible for the development of no
genome editing reagents including cts
cas9 which is the focus of today's
webinar pandita you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone my name is pandita
postnat and i'm the product manager for
genome editing at thermo fisher
scientific
for today's webinar will be discussing
the development of gmp manufactured cas9
protein for therapeutic applications
here are the agendas for today's
training we'll go over some
introductions before talking about key
considerations for therapeutic
researches
we'll then talk about manufacturing
facilities and process controls
safety testing and specifications
and finally end with some performance
data
genome editing has become exceedingly
popular for several applications
due to this crispr craft 9 revolution
crisper cast 9 has been a significant
paradigm shift in functional genomics
research
it has made genome editing accessible to
a wide array of researches like it
wasn't before
as the tool continues to be adopted into
various workflows
over the recent years we are starting to
see another paradigm shift with an
increase in adoption of crispr cas9
technology for therapeutics development
given the recent clinical successes and
commercial approvals in this space we
have also observed an exponential growth
in clinical trial pipelines as well
shown on the graph on the left hand side
you'll see that over the past few years
we have seen an exponential increase in
trials in said pipeline
we have also seen some cell and gene
therapies approved by the fda shown on
the right hand side
does further demonstrate the promise and
growth in the application of crispr
cast-9 technology for therapeutic
development
when thinking about key steps within the
translational pipeline there are four
distinct stages as researchers move
their project from bench to the clinic
from early research and develop
development to pre-clinical studies to
clinical trials and finally
commercialization
as researchers move that project through
this pipeline the requirements for the
critical reagents needed for that
project change
researchers start to look for higher
quality grade reagents to meet increased
quality and regulatory requirements
and often increased volume of reagents
as the demand for that project changed
from small scale to a large
manufacturing scale
now let's talk in more details about the
three key requirements that therapeutic
researchers look for when selecting
their critical reagents to support the
cell and
gene therapy
programs
firstly quality
researchers need to know that the
reagents they select can stand up to
increase quality and regulatory
requirements
secondly supply
researchers are looking for reassurance
that they will be able to purchase the
right amount of reagents they need at
the right time to support their programs
so it is incredibly important for these
researchers that the supplier of their
critical reagents will be able to
produce large lot size consistently
lastly and just as important performance
researchers need and want the highest
performing reagents possible
this means that not only must the
reagents be high performing but it must
also have minimal lot to lot variation
so that they can trust that lot number
one will perform just as well as lot
number 100
these are the three important factors
that researchers look for in their
reagents for their therapeutics programs
and factors to keep in mind when
developing gmp manufactured cath9
protein
with that we have recently launched the
gibco cts truecut cast 9 protein a next
generation cas9 protein designed and
manufactured to support clinical
research programs
our protein maintain high editing
efficiency in primary immune cells and
is manufactured in compliance with gmp
principles
it is also manufactured to meet the
requirements for the standards for
ancillary materials for cell gene and
tissue based products
to ensure adherence to the quality and
regulatory standards we leverage an
aseptic manufacturing process and our
protein is also subjected to extensive
safety testing including sterility
endotoxin and residual hose nucleic acid
and protein
as the latest addition to thermo fischer
scientific cell therapy systems family
of product cts true cut cas9 protein is
designed for cell therapy manufacturing
our cts product is manufactured to
conform with 21 cfr part 820 where
applicable and all at iso 13485
certified site cts products are also
subjected to extensive safety testing
and have traceability documentation
including fda's drug master files
finally our cts product brands have
proven use in several approved cell
therapies and and over 100 clinical
trials
an aspect that is also critical for the
development of gmp manufactured cas9 is
in having the appropriate manufacturing
facilities
it is important that the protein is made
in facilities that can meet the
appropriate quality and regulatory
requirements
as for our cts true cut kas9 product it
is made at our biosciences center of
excellence with dedicated gmp suites and
clean room facilities in accordance to
several regulatory directives and
guidelines
in looking at the manufacturing process
design and controls needed for the
development of gmp manufactured cast 9
shown here is an example schematic of
the manufacturing process
to further control the risk of
contaminants a closed system
manufacturing process that leverage
single-use technology should be used
additional controls from a facility
management perspective is also critical
for example all materials that enter gmp
facilities should be animal origin free
to the secondary level and
beta-lactam-free
to further reduce any risk of
contaminants
a few other considerations for the
manufacturing process of gmp cast 9
include
a process that is capable of producing
large lot size is important
as alluded to earlier having access to a
large single lot can allow researchers
to use the same material lot to support
that program
this could further minimize any
potential variability that may be
introduced when using materials from
different lots
our manufacturing process has a high
yield and can make upwards of 15 gram of
cas9 protein per purification run
to further control contaminant risk
several thorough filtration steps are
designed and added to the process
additionally
in-process controls are also
planned
and designed throughout the
manufacturing workflow as well
furthermore sterile fillings should be
completed in the appropriate cleanroom
suites and safety precautions taken
taken to further reduce the risk of
contaminants
for our manufacturing process all
containers are sterilized with
additional quality control in place
including performing a bioburden test on
the glove used after the assembling step
finally the final filled products are
subjected to extensive release testing
to ensure adherence to the required
standards
for our product specifically the final
field protein is subjected to 17 release
tests again the idea here is
the controls and design that we put in
place from a manufacturing perspective
is done intentionally to
minimize the risk of any contaminants
into the actual product itself
so we take careful consideration when
designing our manufacturing process to
make sure that we have all the right
controls and all the right steps in
place to help minimize those risk so
that we can meet the required standards
in addition to the manufacturing process
design and controls we discussed earlier
there's also another strategy to
physically segregate manufacturing steps
to further minimize contaminant risk so
typically when developing gmp grade
product you should be leveraging both
the design of the process itself as well
as putting that physical layout and
segregation in place as part of your
design
here is an example of the spatial layout
of the gmp manufacturing suites
you'll find that a controlled and
dedicated space is assigned for each key
workflow step where each activity is
done in different clean room grades
you'll see that as we move closer from
the left to the right to the finished
good product the clean room grade
becomes more astringent moving from a
class d
all the way to a class a clean room
and again the idea here is to further
minimize the risk as contamination
overall the development of gmp
manufactured cast 9 leverages both the
manufacturing process design as well as
spatial controls to ensure adherence to
the required quality and regulatory
standards
now that we have looked at the
manufacturing process consideration the
gmp cast 9 is then subjected to
extensive safety testing and release
specifications
these safety testings are performed on
the final finished product to ensure
that it passes all the required
specifications
via thermo fissure scientific our cts
truecat cas9 protein is subjected to 17
qc tests performed on each finished good
lot before release
the release specifications can be
categorized into three distinct groups
each measuring for different source of
potential impurities or contaminants
the first group of assays are product
related impurities
these include identity and purity assays
that measure for any product related
impurities
second group of release testing
include process related impurities as
well as safety
these acids measure the level of
contaminants from various sources
including enzymatic host and process
finally you have characterization these
assays confirm the characteristics of
the final product including
concentration ph and activity
together these release tests help to
ensure that the final gmp manufactured
cast 9 product meet all the
specifications and requirements in
accordance to the appropriate standards
for cell therapy applications
now we're going to move into our
performance data
here we evaluated the performance of our
cts cas9 protein against our research
grade cas9 product
the goal is to assess the effect of gmp
manufacturing process and controls on
product performance
we selected primary t cells as our model
of choice to demonstrate the application
of cts truecad cas9 for autologous
t-cell or carti therapy workflows
from an approach perspective first we
evaluated the protein activity with an
in vitro cleavage assay
next we evaluated the performance of
these proteins in primary t cells at the
small neon electroporation system of 10
microliter
then we scaled up our experiments by 10
fold using the larger scale neon
electroporation system
first we look at the protein activity
using an in vitro cleavage assay the
benefit of this assay is where we are
strictly only looking at the protein
activity
via cleavage activity level
we then diluted the ruo and cts cas9
proteins to a linear range and measure
cleavage activity accordingly
you see on the left hand side in the
graph that across our tested protein
dosage on the x-axis the activity
between the rule and cts cas9 proteins
are comparable
this result suggests that cts cast 9 was
able to maintain in vitro cleavage
activity across doses relative to the
ruo cas9
next we wanted to confirm the activity
of the cts cas9 protein observe in vitro
and to make sure that it is still
preserved when transferred to a cellular
environment
as mentioned we selected primary t cells
for these experiments as they offer the
appropriate cellular contacts needed for
car t cell therapy development workflow
we selected seven guide rnas targeting
four car t-cell related therapeutic
genes
these guides include those used in
literature as well as some other
in-house selected options
for this experiment we leverage the
standard or small bench top scale neon
electroporation system of 10 microliter
we looked at cell viability and editing
efficiency from the two proteins
when looking at the cell viability shown
on the left hand side here we observed
that both protein yielded high viability
or low toxicity
then we measured the editing efficiency
using next generation sequencing and saw
that both ruo and cts cas9 proteins
perform comparably from a performance
perspective
these results suggest that lcts cas9
proteins have comparable functional
performance relative to the research
grade cast 9 and that the gmp
manufacturing process did not negatively
affect performance
wanting to evaluate the cts cas9
performance further at a larger scale we
also evaluated both proteins at 10x
scale up using the larger neon
electropuration platform of 100
microliter
once again we look at cell viability and
editing efficiency
this time we selected four guide rnas
from the previous seven to do further
analysis
similarly you'll find that the cell
viability shown on the left hand side
once again is comparable between the two
protein
then for editing efficiency in this
specific experiment we wanted to
evaluate both indel and hdr from both
proteins
hdr or homology directed repair is the
pathway that is important for
therapeutic researchers as it enables
more precise edits
for hdr assessment we use single strand
oligos as our donor and for our
electroporation we use a genome editing
buffer that is optimized for knock-in
application
across the four guide rnas we assessed
we were able to achieve high hdr
percentage for both proteins
then when looking at the overall editing
efficiency shown as a number on top of
the graph right here you'll see that the
bo that birth protein once again achieve
comparable efficiency across all targets
at the 10x scale up
these results further confirm that gmp
manufacturing process did not have a
negative impact on performance
it further confirms that high hdr
percentage can be achieved with the cts
cas9 protein at large scale
finally we assess the quality and
performance of the cts truecad cast 9
across three different manufacturing
lots
here we perform the experiment in
primary t cells targeting two genes and
using two guide rnas
serial dilution was performed to better
interrogate the editing efficiency
achieved with decreasing protein amount
at the first target track 4 shown on the
left hand side you'll find that
comparable editing efficiency is
observed across all three manufacturing
lots
throughout the dilution range
we also saw a similar trend and
performance at the second target as well
shown on the right hand side of cd526
both these results showed that
consistent lots a lot performance was it
was achieved
this is a direct indication of a very
tightly controlled manufacturing process
which we talked about earlier
in summary there are three key
requirements that therapeutic
researchers look for when selecting
their critical reagents
quality
once again we talked that robust
manufacturing process and control is
necessary to make sure that we keep
safety risk to the minimal
secondly is supply
today we talked about the importance of
high yield manufacturing process
which would help minimize risk of
performance and variability and also
assist in supply continuity
lastly we talked about performance as
mentioned high performing reagents with
minimal lot to lot variation is
important for therapeutic programs
these requirements are the key drivers
when designing the manufacturing process
or the development for gmp manufactured
cast 9 for therapeutic applications
with that i want to thank everyone for
your time and we will now open the floor
for questions and answers
great thank you pandita for the very
informative presentation
we will now start our live q a session
portion of the webinar if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and go ahead and hit send and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
with that let's go ahead and get started
as the questions are starting to come in
the pandita
i know that you also have a
research-grade version of this cas9
protein can you expand a little bit on
the differences between that research
grade and the ct cts grade product
yeah that's a really good question so um
i know i kind of touched on this as well
in the presentation right so i'm just so
confirmed that both of our ruo and cts
cas9 proteins are the same protein from
a functional perspective
um you know we saw uh i just showed you
this in a couple of slides ago that both
have comparable performance
um right but so so the difference is the
key differences here is that with the
cts true cut cast 9 protein
with that additional sort of values
coming from the cts brand we offer more
documentation to meet regulatory
requirements and as you saw as well
right the protein itself is also
subjected to
tighter quality controls including more
process controls extensive safety
testing as well as release
specifications so that's sort of the the
key differences i would say between the
ru and the cts
cas9 protein
good thank you
um you tested i know you tested some t
cells with the cts gas sign did you test
any other cell types besides t cells
yeah and i feel like i should have
mentioned that too in the presentation
right but as you saw um so the data that
i showed today are all in t cells but we
have also tested the cts truecadcast
nine in ipscs as well
and and the intent of that was to mimic
um kind of its use in that allogeneic
workflow because we talked a lot um and
i talked a lot in this presentation
about autologous so so we did tests and
ipscs
but as mentioned um again the the
primary reason why we i chose to display
primary t cells was because it's our
model of choice for its representation
of autologous t cell application
or car t cell therapy development
workflow but we did as i said meant
we also tested in ipscs as well yeah
and i noticed that you also used the
neon electro-operation platform did you
have you guys tested any other platforms
or any more high throughput versions
yeah so um yeah so we tested um in
obviously the 10 microliter and the 100
microliter and the purpose of that was
just to kind of mimic our use case of
that small scale electroporation
but we did also kind of to answer that
question right we also did
think about large scale up so we also
have tested the cts truecadcast 9 in our
cts xenon electroporation system um and
for those who may not be very familiar
our xenon electroporation system just
launched um last month and it's our
large scale electroporation platform so
we also did experiments in the on that
platform as well i didn't show that data
today but we um you know have that
information and we've kind of tested it
and confirmed that um the performance
didn't drop as we change our
electroporation um sort of volume all
conditions which is great
that's great i think that high volume
exploration is going to be important for
this application moving forward
i think especially for therapeutics
application right if you think about it
it's like um you're going to want to do
the small scale
experiments which is where the neon
comes in perfectly before kind of
scaling that up to the xenon so having
access to both platform and having
reagents that work well on both platform
i think it's going to be really
important for therapeutic applications
yeah
so there's a question here about
stability so i know in your presentation
it looks like you showed some data about
some of the lot to lot variability of
the cts cas9 maybe you can comment a
little bit more on stability on the cts
cast 9 protein itself any other data or
experiments you guys performed
yeah so um at timeout of launch we have
a real-time stability data to support
12-month shelf life
and currently we're testing additional
time points so those are being collected
right now um with the intent of you know
assessing for a potential shelf life
extension in the future
but just at the time of launch as i said
we have 12 months
and that information is actually going
to be on your cfa as well when you
purchase the product um and then as far
as additional stability experiments we
did do some short-term stability
experiments as well on the cts cas9 rnp
which as you recall rnp is when you
complex the protein with the guide rna
right in various
conditions
um and one of the example
sort of use case that we leveraged was
to leave that cts cast 9 rnp at room
temperature for an extended period of
time and again the thought here is that
we wanted to mimic what you know
researchers would do
in a situation where you're doing like
high throughput workflow
so from this experiment we actually
found that our cts cast 9 rnp is quite
stable and again i think that speaks to
the manufacturing process and the
controls that we put in we just were
able to achieve that um kind of high
purity uh product making it quite stable
at room temperature for an extended
period of time i think our time point
goes up until like 16 hours which is um
you know obviously kind of uh what we
wanted to mimic as i said in case in
case researchers are doing high
throughput workflow and they need to
leave those reagents out on the bench
for
a longer time
about 16 hours that gives them a lot of
flexibility to design your experiment
and use it that's that's great
information right
exactly and that was why we asked that
questions and wanted to do that
experiments to see um you know what that
would look like just mimicking a couple
of different use conditions
um yeah
yeah excellent
there's a question around is the drug
master file available on the cts cas9
protein
yeah so
as i said right this is kind of part of
the
um value of our cts brand product as
well in that we
offer that additional documentation so
for the cts cas9 yes the drug master
file will be available
so that's something that we
also have a process in place if if you
know any researchers wants to request it
there's a kind of a um
almost like a form or a form field for
them to fill um to request that drug
master file but yes we do have that and
we will have that available for this
product
great excellent
and there was a question from from a
jenny and sorry i didn't quite
understand the question so maybe if that
person could resubmit their question
i'll be able to
ask it to pandita but in the meantime
while um they're typing that maybe you
could just tell us a little bit more
about where
they can get more information about the
cts cas9
yeah um so obviously so
as i said we just launched this product
a couple weeks ago so if you go you know
on thermofisher.com
um you're going to be able to find a lot
of information on cts cast 9 as well as
some of the additional data actually
will be on when you type the product
into the search bar on thermofisher.com
um you'll be taken to
our product page and actually on that
page we also have additional data that i
didn't show today so some of the ipsc's
data
will be kind of available there as well
and so you know i feel like that's
probably um the best place to get all
your information and of course we also
have a number of application notes
as well on this product that if you are
interested you can also find that online
on thermofisher.com um but also if you
know you go on thermofisher.com and you
don't see what you're looking for um
please feel free to reach out to me
directly as well and i can um direct you
to the appropriate team i'll get you the
information that you you may be looking
for
right
and then there's a question that came in
regarding the rnp complex and i think
they're talking about must have been
when you were talking about stability
size and everything and they want to
know a little bit more about how you've
prepared that complex
um
so maybe you could just spend a little
bit more on that
yeah so as far as preparing that rnp
complex um actually so i just wanted to
point out as well we followed the
protocol that we have so we have a user
manual on this product online and it's
our standard protocol as far as you know
kind of mixing the cast 9 with our
synthetic guide rna
to form that rnp complex um so if you
would like additional information on
like the exact protocol the ratio that
we use i would actually recommend going
to that user manual just to get the
exact numbers um but that's sort of the
the the process that we followed
um i i don't want to to go into too much
detail today but i you know like like i
said the exact information and the
protocol that we use for the preparation
of the cts cast 9 rnp is in the user
manual with the exact ratio as well as
our electroporation conditions that we
use on the xenon is sorry on the neon is
also in that user manual as well so um
certainly something that i can share
with with you directly
and you'll be able to sort of
um
you know see all the different
conditions that we use for this
experiment and the data that showed
great
thank you just waiting to see if any
other additional questions come in
that looks like it's about it so
anyways all right with that so i wanted
to thank you again pandita for your time
today you know we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor thermal
official scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time to
answer today or
we will follow up
um afterwards and uh we'll give up we'll
definitely reach out to you um the
webcast can be viewed on on demand
laboratories will alert you one via
email when it's available to replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until then
thank you everyone for your time today
and have a great rest of your day thank
you
you